but you see
you can't tell people that
and just by telling get them to see it
just in an exactly this way you people
who know that the Earth is flat
can't be reasoned with
people who believe that the Bible is the
literal word of God absolutely
impossible to reason with them at all
because they know it is so
so in the same way
we tend to know
that we are all separate poor little me
and that we are in need of Salvation or
something
and we know this so and so somebody says
well you are not really that you know
that that feeling of separateness is an
illusion
well that's all very nice in theory but
I don't feel it
so what will you do
what will you do with a person who is
convinced that the Earth is flat
no way of reasoning with him
if it's for some reason important that
he discovered that the Earth is round
you've got to play a game with him you
want to play a trick on him you tell him
great the Earth is flat let's go and
look over the edge
wouldn't that be fun
of course if we're going to look over
the edge of the Earth we must be very
very careful that we don't go around in
circles or we'll never get to the edge
so we've got to go along consistently
along a certain line of latitude
westwards
and then
we're going to come to the edge of the
Earth just so long as we're consistent
in other words in order to convince a
flat artist
that the world is round you've got to
make him act consistently on his own
proposition
and go consistently westwards to find
the edge of the world now at last when
he by going consistently westwards he
comes back to the place where he started
he's been convinced that the Earth is at
least cylindrical
and he may believe you then take it on
faith that if he goes along a line of
longitude the same thing will happen
but you see what you did
was to make him persist in his follower
now that's the whole method of Zen
to make people
become
perfect
be good